joining us tour bond south carolina
senator tim scott center i'm i'm
i thought the speech was amazing i'm i'm
sorry
uh it saddens me i have many
conservative african-american friends
and they go through the same thing read
janine borrelli's book blacklash just
google my name that's what she starts
well sean thank you for having me on
your show and thank you in lindsey last
night vote timscott.com
your viewers heard your your request or
lindsay's request and you responded so
thank you so much for that
the left has lost their mind today it's
really saddening to see that
what the left is doing is fighting
bigotry with bigotry
and they've exposed their hypocrisy and
their true motivation
has nothing to do with ending prejudice
it has everything to do with claiming
or getting more power i've never seen
such a
power grab and using people
in such a despicable way it it is really
disheartening to see the left's response
and frankly
even twitter's response to racism and
racial slurs
if it comes from the left it must be
okay according to
twitter's response 12 hours later but
thanks to your viewers viewers for going
to
vogtimsky.com thank you all so much that
really made a difference because
lindsay's right the next several months
if not the next two years of my life
will be standing
in the gap for what we know as
traditional
american values we love people
not parties we love the content not the
color
our nation stands in greatness because
we
fought back against those darker angels
and we believed frankly in the better
angels
i wish the democrats who always feign
or virtue signal would take a look in
the mirror and ask themselves
would they put up with that from anyone
other than themselves
and if you won't police yourselves
don't look to the other side you know
megan mccain actually said something i
agree with if
if you're okay with this don't don't
talk to me about the important issue
involving race and i i thought that was
pretty powerful statement on her
on behalf of her you know i'm watching
all of this unfold
sad because i've we've known each other
now many years
uh yeah and it's just it's just wrong
and the
and it's in this won't cancel culture it
seems like there's very few areas where
this type of intolerance is accepted
and it seems to be accepted by major
news organizations
do you have a message to them
specifically tonight
well in my opinion what they're fueling
is a backlash
maybe they don't realize it or not but
at some point people get sick and tired
of being sick and tired
and they start reacting and as as
opposed to responding
to the criticism and the negativity
fortunately for me i've had in do
have had to endure for the last couple
of years as i keep coming to the
conclusion
that we got it right the most inclusive
economy
frankly in american history the last
administration president trump we
created
seven million jobs with two-thirds going
to african-americans
and hispanics and women we saw the
lowest unemployment rate we didn't care
whether you were black or white
we looked for ways to expand
opportunities
and give people options to make their
own decisions
that's what america is about and sure
we've had some challenges but we keep
rising to the occasion
we confront the person in the mirror
which allows us to move over but
the the left sean the left refuses to do
that
the left wants to find a fall guy they
want to find a scapegoat
as opposed to helping build a better
america what they want to do
is spend six trillion dollars where are
we going to get it from
they don't care to do what to make sure
that they have a
permanent underclass people they think
they can control
but what i'm seeing and i spoke with
president trump today what we're seeing
happen
is this response from good intention
people
who happen to be black who happen to be
hispanic who happen to be white who
happen to be asian
rising up and saying you won't tell me
what to think
i'm going to decide that for myself so
there's a coming
backlash to this liberal oppression that
is becoming
front and center and they're not even
hiding their hands anymore sean
that's why it's so important that we
stand in the gap for this nation
because the greatest comeback in
american history
is on its way you know it's amazing here
you did you gave specific examples of
racism
nobody's doubted there are there are
ignorant racist people
there are evil people in this world and
and nobody that i know wants anything to
do with those ignorant people that
that's whatever subset group of people i
think the majority of americans are good
honest decent people
the beauty of our framers and founders i
would argue
you can agree or disagree is that they
created a system where you can right
wrongs correct injustices become a more
perfect union
we have a history of doing all of that
and a lot of bloodshed in the process
and a lot of
heroism and courage along the way by
people of all races
um and and then i'm like but joe biden
how does he get away with praising the
guy that
filibustered the civil rights act of 64
the voting rights act of 65
partner to stop the integration of
public schools saying he doesn't want
schools to be racial jungles
and not one person on nbc news or in the
media mob
or in the democratic party seems to care
about that history
because maybe i'm wrong senator scott
but if a republican
donald trump or any other republican had
that background in history
i'm pretty sure they would criticize
them daily but what do i know i'm just
oh my goodness
it would be unrelenting there's no doubt
about that sean we would be
we would have a a cascading effect we
would never see the light of day because
we would be
the drumming would never stop the truth
of the matter is the hypocrisy
needs to stop i am a black man i am
proud to be black
i happen to be a conservative because i
came to the conclusion a long time ago
that conservative policies and
principles
is the way that we set people free free
to be whoever they want to be
you actually are free to disagree with
me that's the beauty of america
and what the democrats are selling is
that you are not free to be yourself
you cannot disagree with the democrats
you can't disagree with progressives and
liberals
and still you see let me ask that's the
mainstream of this country
two last questions why does joe biden
get a pass on his background his history
and what did donald trump say to you
today
number one uh i'll start with good news
and go to bad news good news is
president trump called me to
just tell me that he thought i did a
spectacular job and you know president
trump he's effused in his phrase
at times and he said it was fantastic it
was spectacular
he really enjoyed listening to it i'm
glad that he listened to it period
number one and he wants to make sure
that we keep working to get more things
done for the country
believe it or not one of the things that
we talked about for a very short period
of time
was how do we make progress for the most
vulnerable
he is still focusing on getting things
done from a policy standpoint by
encouraging us
to continue down the path that leads to
american progress
on the other side i've asked the same
question the 1994
biden prison bill was a prison bill it
incarcerated disproportionately african
americans
can you imagine any republican talking
about putting people
back in chains or saying that if you
don't vote for me
you're not black i i don't know what it
is about this paternalism
that comes from the left but it is front
and center
and it is shameful i'm actually saddened
for them because
they are going to continue unless we
stand in that gap
to teach people that this nation and who
we
are is antithetical to the actual
reality that i have lived
my grandfather has lived daniel cameron
john james
ben carson and the list just goes on
once again thank you sean for for your
work and thank you and lindsay for
helping me raise resources at
votetimscott.com
your race is important you're up in 2022
but you know one thing i do know
and i talked to a lot of my friends in
south carolina they were
never more proud of you than last night
and um
thank you sir for being with us and i am
sorry you had had to go through that the
last 24 hours thanks for being with us
thank you sean have a great show thank
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else